caps faithful who are fans of the American Hockey
League's Hershey Bears they recognize that name
dord from last spring as dord makes the stop
he was the net Miner for Coachella Valley in
the cder Cup Final bear long wrer swallowed up
by dord there's no rebound on a takeaway check
barari to the front came right on through it'll
bounce back through Center and start gour the
other way through three on two developing cross
ice for bork strand he snapped It Wide farari put
an armar on tanev as petti picks up oetkin through
Center that cross- ice relay just off the toe of
the blade of Max petti taneva hit machine for the
crack and turned it over Slap Shot oetkin denied
and he's been out of the lineup here and there
not out of the lineup but out of practice and
making sure he's ready for games points and five
straight for Alex long drop by bear secured by
dord Ethan Bay beay now playing with his fourth
different NHL Squad strome feeds Edmonson finds
oetkin and a better save by dord at the end of
the line and he's quick get back hting the puck
he got it up in a hurry and there's a beautiful
three-way passing play the cord's best save on
oetkin there on a sharp angle nice little Play All
Around joining the rush Edmonson finds Obie Obie
another opportunity the Cap's cap lson will zigzag
through Center and scale one in Edmonson first to
it greeted by gor sport to the slot Schulz fires
he had that one armed away we know Justin Schulz
from his time in DC loves to be involved at the
offensive Edge B an excellent skater and a great
mind for the game picks the right spots to jump
into the play Schulz fan on the clearing effort
McMichael off the de wonderful stop by dord
going in DC McMichael off the head fake Just
fored moment for Max Pat ready and Locker you
could hear the emotion in his voice as the Kraken
look for a chance here with Schwarz firing off
the outside of the post another positive thought
at the outset of this contest see TJ flying around
and feeling comfortable kaken with speed through
center it's McCain on the drop snapshot here
scores it finds a home off the blade of cier
cier what a shot I mean that's a good transition
play it looked like to me they had numbers back
amage you can also play Wing he's back and forth
but he lugs the male up the ice and look at the
numbers back the Caps are in good shape but that
skips right past a couple of Defenders you can
see the reaction of keer that he didn't see this
shot and there it is going right by him on the
short side Maan the nice drop and there's the
shot little bit of traffic cross trafficing a
little bit of a step but he angled him perfectly
to take away that chance on the move this pass is
just a bit strong for McAn his centering feet
knocked away at Point position borgan plays it
south of the goal line man rdik greeted by
cier as who Nets off looks for the lengthy
feed that'll skip wide of dord wraparound attempt
from Oshi shut down by the Seattle net minder to
go fast moving opening period dord had to be quick
post to post to beat 77 there looking things over
bear from the severe angle a pad stop for dord oi
cradles It on Back edmonson's Drive is deflected
stopped in front of the Seattle net minder Al you
and Mitch know that the capitals have 11 comeback
victories this season including their most recent
one come from behind effort against the Kings dlan
fires glove save Darcy keer knocks him down in
the corner Bor strand pedaling back with Schulz
through Center Schulz to the outside on the delay
gourd pumped that one right to the pads of keer
intermission live Alexa landestoy and Alan May
standing by rebound right at the doorstep Ethan
Bay working back through Center Edmonson gets
up into the flow his drop pass for malen Stein
forced Away by tanev windberg cruising in with
a snap shot he's scores Alex glenberg yep he can
really fire it notice the first two shots are
just quick releases but they're on the attack
the Caps didn't get the pucky at the caps and here
they come and it's just wber just curl and dragon
then through the defenseman uh bear and bear uh
screen on the goenda and he just rips it notice
the curl that dragged a little bit of a slide by
windberg and wber late oetkin turns the corner on
his backand swiving to the front Patti glanced
that one out of Play Still 1.7 to go in the
first dzone starts at a premium for that
line obey cubel play a top side for Jensen
obey cubel off of his first career pre-point
game to cord made a save there from Deep who
was trying to set a screen in front of the
net no icing here against Seattle it would
have been what a weird bounce off the
corner wall there oetkin down the flank
feeds it through beautiful pass score Max
pater ready off of a great relay from Dylan
strome to the training staff starts with a
good speed breakout TV rink wide that little
pass coming through there and a beautiful
pass off the wing watch Obie stro lets it
go through I don't even think he T he touched
it Locker he did well the D hit it and it goes
through here it is one more time maybe off
the heel of his stick and there it is five
hole on the play mantha returns it to Bear
stick checked by Alexi turning and burning
Seattle has numbers Vince dun three on one dun
fires P save on both ways odd man breaks here
comes Seattle Vince Dunn looking to make a pass
elects to shoot it look like he was shooting
for a rebound got the rebound but it's on that
basket for sure folks the All-Star voting Ends
Tonight just uh before midnight Seattle at the
offensive end here you can vote at nhl.com vote
doorstep backand touched home Schulz helped to
create it Seattle gets the two- goal lead back
it sure looked like from up here that Schulz
net Drive threw it off the left pad and Then
followed up for his own rebound there with a
buck 40 to go left side of the screen a little
shimmy there gets a little give and go down low
there's the first shot it goes off a caps player
in front of the net and then it goes right in
back to him and Schulz the former Cap's going
to have a two goal lead for his hockey team
the play in front made by stro doesn't collect
it veneers who played collegiately at Michigan
the head man to Tatar toas Tatar nice catch
working on the overlap with ever lead back
to Tatar backand try snuffed out by keer and
that's a heck of a stop right there look at him
close his pads in a hurry doesn't look around I
think he knows that it's underneath him look
at shake his head at the end of that play no
no no that ain't going in you look at him little
Shake there of the head nope nice try Tatar can't
find the five hole there that left pad down hard
and firm and I have to think that the cord had
he won would have been the MVP because Hunter
Shepard was the MVP who was is fantastic also
is a wonderfully goal tended series between those
two clubs lson rolls through Center feed for ten
get it back to the front he scores a beautiful
goal for Adam lson given go with speed we talk
about the D being part of the attack well
there you see the Seattle defense jumping
up points per game and here you'll see Adam
Larson jumping up in the play a give and go
with tan and talk about you know we talk about
lifted passes what about this pass by TANF look
at how high it goes and it lands flat that is
unbelievable an aerial pass that comes down
as flat as it left tanav stick thear will play
keep away Seattle so far so good on a six-game
road swing they beat buffalo on Tuesday they take
down Washington in DC Thursday by the final of 4-1